[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide coming to
you from snowy's Sundance in Park City
and I'm about to give you five movies
that you should put on your radar so
let's start with what is right now my
favorite film of the festival wildlife
which is the directorial debut for Paul
Dino the actor and at certain the 1950s
in Montana based on a book and it's an
emotional family drama with an
incredible performance by Carey Mulligan
who plays the mother then there's future
husband Jake Gyllenhaal who plays the
father and a young kid called Edie oxen
bold as the son stunningly shot
impressive debut for Paul Day know who
has got a great eye it shows that he's
not only a talented actor but he's also
going to be a very talented director too
[Music]
American animals is a very interesting
mix between a narrative heist film and
documentary style interviews it's based
on a true story about a group of college
students who plotted to steal some rare
books from the library but I love the
way that they interject the narrative
story with the real interviews from the
people which also plays with the idea of
memory is got a great young cast
including Evan Peters and Barry kyogen
[Music]
generation wealth is a fascinating
documentary by photographer Loren
Greenfield who has been studying the
effects of wealth for many many decades
this brings all her work together she
revisits to some of the subjects that
she took photos of in the 90s and the
2000s and it's also a personal film for
her as she looks at how maybe she has
become a workaholic through her
dedication to the project it's a
fascinating and disturbing look at the
damage of excess and always wanting more
[Music]
another one I really recommend is the
powerful and confronting movie The Tale
this was written and directed by
Jennifer Fox and it's based on her own
life
the character of Jenny is played by
Laura Dern and she is trying to grapple
with the idea of the relationship she
had when she was 13 with a much older
man which at the time she thought was a
real relationship full of love and she
comes to realize slowly that it was
sexual abuse it's very beautifully
structured going back and forth through
her memories as her story that she's
been telling herself all these years
starts to crumble oh I definitely had
needed a lot of tissues in it another
film that I really enjoyed is called
Leave No Trace and this is directed by
Debra Granik who did Winter's Bone many
many years ago this is a return to
scripted feature films for her and once
again it's about a young girl this time
played by Thomas & McKenzie a brilliant
young Kiwi actress and it follows her
and her father who's played by Ben
Foster as they navigate his PTSD after
being in the Army trying to live off the
grid in a park out of society and stay
together as a family it takes at a time
but it packs an emotional punch
really is well worth the work
and there's plenty more films here at
the Sundance Film Festival 122 features
in total 37 percent is directed by women
53 by news filmmakers it's incredible
and if you want to see more reviews make
sure you follow me on twitter at Alicia
Malone and I'll see you soon
[Music]